rated M for Mature
welcome to Sniper Elite 3 a tactical
shooter that rewards stealth planning
and execution with thrilling emergent
gameplay and genre-defining ballistics
Africa 1942 Allied forces faced the
overwhelming light of Germany's infamous
Africa Corps intelligence warned of Nazi
von devatha wonder weapons that
threatened to turn the tide of the
entire war
you are Carl Fairburn an OSS agent and
elite sniper
skilled in stealth sabotage and ranged
combat you are as lethal up close and
personal
as ran from a distance the exotic
terrain and expensive environments of
North Africa offer a wealth of tactical
and gameplay opportunities from twisting
canyons to lush Oasis and ancient cities
every combat theater encourages
exploration where your objectives can be
tackled in any order observe your
surroundings using binoculars to tag
enemy patrols officers and snipers and
reveal multiple opportunities that can
be exploited for a crucial combat
advantage a blind spot in the Patrol a
hidden Ridgeline with a deadly view or a
tempting choke point for an explosive
ambush
came to the shadows and so chaos amongst
the enemy hunt stragglers with silenced
pistols and then lay takedowns
use various combinations of your lethal
inventory to lure patrols into explosive
traps and sabotage access equipment to
mask the sound of your rifle shots
take out long-range targets with Sniper
Elite 3 genre leading ballistics must
take account of the effect that wind
gravity even your heartbeat has on
bullet travel before taking a deep
breath to steady your aim and pulling
the trigger see your bullet tracked by
the series acclaimed x-ray kill camera
simulating in detail the impact of a
rifle shot on enemy muscle layers organs
bones and circulatory system it's not
just human enemies who should fear your
lethal aim using Sniper Elite threes
multistage vehicle takedowns expert
snipers can pick apart mechanized foes
from a distance and watch their internal
destruction rendered in incredible
detail
the Africa Corps are a worthy foe and
you'll need to adapt quickly to survive
as your first shots ring out ends will
head for cover
prioritize enemy officers and snipers
while you have the upper hand continue
firing and they will locate you
commanding soldiers to flank your
position and flush you out it's time to
relocate as the enemy zero in on your
last known location keep a low profile
relocate successfully and the enemy will
call off their search so you can renew
the hunt on your own terms with a new
tactical approach one bullet
can change history
you
you